[Music]
this is a spherical orb metallic in the
Middle East 2022 by an MQ-9 we see these
all over the world and we see these
making very interesting apparent
Maneuvers this one in particular however
I would point out demonstrated no
enigmatic technical capabilities and was
no threat to Airborne safety while we
are still looking at it I don't have any
more data other than that
thank you
there's a whole Fleet of them look on
the Asa
oh my gosh
this is a newly released video you'll
notice there are two dots moving back
and forth and we went even deeper looked
at Air Traffic Control Data we were able
to match those to aircraft on a major
flight Corridor heading into a major
airport for Landings
six five four three two
a real stigma among people reporting
events we feel many events remain
unreported
commercial pilots for example are very
reluctant
to report anomalies
and one of our goals in having NASA play
a role is to remove stigma and get high
quality data
[Music]